des sacs de plastique contaminée en
provenance du canada
ces conteneurs sont pourtant censés être
rempli de matières recyclables la
malaisie en a assez pas question de
devenir un dépotoir pour les pays riches
nous allons renvoyer 60 conteneurs donc
trois mille tonnes d'ordures dans leur
pays d'origine comme le canada a déclaré
la ministre malaisienne de
l'environnement depuis des années des
entreprises canadiennes envoient des
matières dites recyclables dans des pays
étrangers comme en malaisie qui autorise
l'importation de déchets de plastique
propre et homogène pour les recycler
maintenant ça ne veut pas dire que tout
ce qui le met dans un conteneur
correspond exactement à la désignation
de ce qu'ils prétendent vendre
[Musique]
résultat dix tonnes de déchets se
retrouvent dans ces pays sous de faux
prétextes redouane de prétexte au rebut
saclay une crise latente exacerbée l'an
dernier lorsque la chaîne a cessé
d'importer des matières recyclables les
pays voisins se sont donc engouffrés
dans ce marché des usines de recyclage
ont vu le jour par dizaines
certaines sans autorisation sans respect
des normes environnementales dont
profitent les entreprises canadiennes
ils n'ont aucune technologie où ils
n'ont pas de capacité de faire quelque
chose je l'avais bas ils abandonnent
parfois ils abandonnent dans la nature
un mois après que les philippines aient
déclaré la guerre aux poubelles
canadienne la malaisie exhorte les
gouvernements étrangers de prendre leurs
responsabilités
christie a fui l'aisne compte en parler
à sa collègue au ministère de
l'environnement
c'est important dû régler la situation
si vite possible
parce que si rien n'est fait d'autres
pays suivront les traces de la malaisie
et des philippines et la crise de la
gestion mondiale des déchets pourrait se
transformer en guerre commerciale
issigeac audrey charbonneau radio canada
mon frère